[Music]
welcome back now we're leading the news
today with the tragic story that two
seventeen year olds have died in two
separate knife attacks less than 24
hours apart last year there are more
than 40,000 incidents involving blades
that's more than 100 a day the Justice
Minister is Rory Stewart and he joins us
now from just outside Freeman in Cumbria
and thank you very much for being with
us this morning and I just want to start
on knife crime what's happening on our
streets well the first thing is a really
relentless focus on bringing together a
team across the police and intelligence
agencies to get to grips with what's
driving this nice crime and how to make
it more difficult so that's everything
from making it more difficult to
actually acquire knives in the first
place getting into schools looking at
education programs making sure that we
understand the connection between knife
crimes and drugs and putting investment
in and one of the reasons why we've put
hundreds of millions pounds more into
the police and into the intelligence
services is precisely because these
kinds of issues now you're moving on to
other issues because we've got a lot to
you and talk about today of course and
you've got a bit of a reputation as one
of perhaps one of the most eloquent
defenders of Teresa Mays brexit deal
it's coming back to a parliament soon
and goodness knows it doesn't in a few
defenders because it was absolutely
historically defeated last time are you
confident it's gonna get through this
time around I don't think one can ever
say that once confident in in this
particular world but I think there's
been a huge amount of movement I think
that people are becoming more pragmatic
they're recognizing much more than they
did in the past that there are a limited
number of alternatives to this and that
the alternatives are worse but I think
people are also beginning to acknowledge
that this if we can deliver it will
allow us to move on it will give this
uncertainty it will bring investment
into the country so it could actually be
a very positive opportunity for the
country and I'm hoping on the 12th of
March that colleagues not just from the
conservative side but also from the
Labour side will join us and saying that
this is the chance to get this done
you sound very optimistic there but the
same time MPs are still absolutely
bitterly split on whether or not this is
an acceptable deal or not I mean that's
prisons Minister do you just want to
lock them all up in the House of Commons
until they finally get some kind of
agreement
well I've long felt that I have long
felt that if we could put 650 MPs in a
room and lock the door we'd get some
kind of agreement but we've moved on
from that now I think we're now in a
world where we can see painfully because
we've all been through it together
you and the media the public voters
members of parliament just how difficult
this negotiation has been and I think
people are beginning to recognize that
this is the deal that gives us control
over immigration but it also keeps very
close economic political diplomatic ties
to Europe which are vital for our
economy and provides a really good
foundation for going forward I mean I
think if we can land this and we're now
only now nine days away from it if we
can land this it really could be the
beginning of a great opportunity for
Britain it could be a great next 5-10
years but we're going to have to get
through this okay well it's good to know
that we've moved on from the idea of
looking MPs up in a room together that
is good news
and if Teresa Mae's deal does fall MPs
will be faced with a choice over delay
to article 50 or leaving with no deal so
you're someone who I'm sure has given
this a great amount of thought what do
you think should happen in that
circumstance well I think that the first
thing to understand is that all those
other options are worse than the Prime
Minister's deal and I hope people are
focusing on this because if you think
that through extension to article 50
which is going to be a vote which would
effectively give let's say a couple of
months extension would resolve nothing
it would put us in a world in which we
were still in a zombie world not knowing
where we're going and it would increase
the chance of other options that would
increase the chance either of people
pushing for general elections which
wouldn't solve everything for another
referendum which I think would solve
nothing at all it would just tell us
what we already know which is that the
country is divided or it would push
people towards a customs union which
would stop as being able to trade with
the rest of the world so all these other
options are worse options which is why
apart from the fact I genuinely believe
this is a positivity and it's the deal
that can really work
for the economy we need to vote for the
Prime Minister's deal but which one
would you pick
I mean the last time this was put before
Parliament the government suffered the
worst defeat of any government ever and
it's not an unreasonable question to ask
that if that is if it's defeated again
which one would you choose out of no
deal or an extension to article 15
personally I think we would have to be
forced into an extension for article 50
but I think people need to understand
that that is a worse option than the
Prime Minister's deal it's not where we
want to be it's not where I want to be I
think these are horrible options the
reason I've been trying to passionately
argue for the Prime Minister's deal from
the beginning is that I think the nearly
two years negotiations a lot of very
very talented people have come up with a
good deal and it would be ridiculous to
reject this opportunity for these
uncertain and worse futures is the
government planning to whip the vote on
knodell I don't know what the answer
that is that's the decision for the
Chief Whip so that that would remain to
be decided I think we do know that
judging by the votes that have happened
in the past that there doesn't seem to
be a parliamentary majority for no deal
but we will see what happens on the day
after but just again to appeal to
colleagues I mean keep going around this
again and again in a circle but getting
this deal through is the answer to all
these problems we don't want to be
driven into these other things nobody
wants a new general election I think a
referendum would be deeply divisive I
think the there are no good alternative
proposals on the table so let's get
behind this deal
so could you vote for No Deal then if
the government were to whip in that way
would you resign I've made it very very
clear from beginning that I'm not
resigning I've promised to resign I'm a
prisons minister I promise to resign
about prisons I'm trying to improve
presence and I've put my job on the line
saying that if I don't manage to improve
presence I'll resign over that and I'm
supporting the Prime Minister very
strongly I think she's done an
unbelievably good job I think we owe her
a lot of respect if we can get this vote
through on the 12th I think people
should have huge admiration for him I'm
definitely not threatening to resign
okay fair enough to carry resign once
and given the
take the prisons I think the chances of
presiding over prisons and not are not
insignificant the National Audit Office
found for example and that the probation
will reforms carried out by your
predecessor Chris Grayling
when he was the justice secretary not
only failed to reduce reoffending but
led to skyrocketing numbers of released
offenders being returned to prison for
breaching their license I mean when you
took on the job of Prisons minister and
looked around at the situation did you
despair I think we are facing very huge
challenges if you look at prisons
violence has risen steadily for five
years and a lot of this has been driven
by new types of drugs particularly spice
and I really believe that this can be
turned around but the way to turn this
around is to get back to basics it's
about making sure that we really improve
the perimeter security and that we
invest in supporting and training staff
we've got nearly four and a half
thousand more prison officers but it's
now making sure that they're trained
properly and supported properly and I
can already see in places like Leeds or
an Isis prison in London the beginnings
of green shoots the beginning of the
sense that we can turn this around but
it's a very very tough job it's a job
I'm I'm very proud to have I'm very
proud of the present officers and the
work they do but nobody should
underestimate how difficult it is partly
because violence in society is
increasing we began with knife crime
you'll hear about attacks even on on
ambulance workers it is a very troubling
moment and prisons are right at the
centre of that now you perhaps
understand the Middle East most more
than most politicians after walking for
thousands of miles through Afghanistan
Pakistan and Iran so I wanted to talk to
you a bit about the situation in Syria
just as we and the interview you
previously said this about British
jihadis fighting in Syria we have to be
serious about the fact these people are
a serious danger to us and unfortunately
the only way of dealing with them will
be in almost every case to kill them so
I'm interested to know what your
thoughts are on how we should deal with
the wives of Islamic state fighters
people like Shamima Begum how should we
deal with these people
Sophie I think the first thing to say is
that nobody should address them
how much of a threat these people
potentially can be I mean I've spent a
lot of my life working obviously in Iraq
and Afghanistan and people who join Isis
have a very varied assorted very cruel
very savage view of the world so that's
the first thing the second thing is that
there should be very clear consequences
for people who travel abroad one of the
issues has been that it is quite
difficult gathering the right kind of
evidence in the middle of a war zone but
we want to create a system where God
forbid anything like this should happen
in the future we do not end up in a
world in which hundreds of British
citizens think they can somehow with
impunity travel to countries and get
involved in extreme radical terrorist
groups so I'm afraid it's a very
difficult decision and obviously as a
justice minister we have to think very
seriously about our legal obligations
and the way that we treat our citizens
but I think the Home Secretary was right
in the case of Shamima Begum I think it
is important that we find ways of taking
clear action and not suggesting that
somehow this is an innocent or or
acceptable practice to go and fight for
Isis the people who are innocent they
are the children of these their fighters
what should happen to them well we have
a huge obligation to children obviously
everywhere in the world and one of the
things we have been doing is of course
investing heavily and international
development aid making sure children are
properly looked after properly fed even
in the region we've got a lot of money
going into Kurdistan where Shmi of
Aegon's families been a lot of money
going into Lebanon a lot of money and
German British taxpayers money looking
after children and supporting them and
of course we do have obligations to them
but we also have obligations to the
British population we have to think
about our own national security
interests these are not easy things but
I don't think there's some simple answer
to this or some simple way of getting
around the fact that what Shamima Begum
did was wrong and that the group she's
associated with is not just a a a a sort
of joke group I mean this is a group
that genuinely is committed to
atrocities genuinely committed to
killing British people genuine committed
to destroying functioning governments
around the world so I think we have to
find a
way of balancing our natural instincts
of of looking after people with having
to protect our population against very
very dangerous groups and I'm afraid
she's found herself right in the center
of this